all right
so thanks very much for the introduction
and thanks everybody for coming
especially because I know that my talk
is conflicting with the third
presidential debate so thank you for
having all your priorities straight I
guess yeah so I hope to be just as
entertaining and informative as the
debate is maybe maybe we can have just
as substantive a policy discussion okay
yeah and also thank you to the Symons
Institute for inviting me to come it's a
real honor to get to speak in this in
this lecture series and which has had
many great speakers in the past and it's
a really cool series and yeah I'm just
very very thrilled to get the
opportunity to talk to you all a day
today about some research that really
excites me so what am I going to talk
about today I'm going to talk about
something called error correcting codes
so in case you didn't get that that's
Error error error correcting correcting
correcting codes codes cooked so what
does this talk actually about all right
outline outline outline this talk is
about the question how can we
communicate in a noisy environment okay
so let's say that you have some message
and you want to tell it to your friend
and for whatever reason maybe you're in
a noisy room maybe there's a lot of you
know you're on a bad connection
something your friend just can't hear
you like the message isn't getting
through what do you do so one solution
is to just repeat your message again and
again and eventually it'll probably get
through so for example is in the title
of this talk or the title of this slide
you know I really want to make sure that
I'm clear so I just repeated it a bunch
of times actually on that note if I'm
not clear please do feel free to ask
questions that we have the advantage of
a two-way communication here which in
this talk we will not have um anyway
okay so we'd like to communicate we can
repeat things and this actually you know
for humans this works pretty well you
know like if I just repeat my message
again and again eventually I'll get
through and what are the downsides you
know maybe I look like an idiot
repeating myself again and again and
maybe it takes me some time you know it
takes me extra time to talk again and
again and again but whenever I'm in
academic write my time is pretty cheap
so whatever okay so for humans this is a
perfectly reasonable solution but it
turns out if you think about it for for
lots of other things that communicate
like your cell phone to a cell tower
or a satellite to a satellite dish
something like this all of a sudden this
overhead starts to become kind of bad
right so these in these settings we have
these things that are communicating huge
amounts of data in very noisy
environments right these signals are
traveling through space maybe like who
knows what's happening to them and we
really expect these signals to be able
to be transmitted reliably so how is it
the case that these things can transmit
signals reliably without just repeating
themselves and it turns out in this case
repeating yourself if you're one of
these systems is extremely costly it
cost time it cost power and we don't
want to do it so what can we do so these
systems employ something called error
correcting codes and that's what this
talk is about so for the first part of
the talk I'm going to talk of you know
sort of define error correcting codes
talk about what they are and how they
can be used to solve this problem in
communication and turns out there's
actually lots of ways to solve this
problem there's lots of different types
of error correcting codes and
unfortunately I won't be able to talk
about them all tonight even though
they're all super cool and exciting so
instead I'm just gonna focus in on one
fundamental idea in coding theory and
this idea is at the heart of a family of
codes called reed-solomon codes which
have been incredibly important over the
past 60 years in communication storage
and lots of other areas and so this
fundamental idea okay wait for it two
points determine a line okay so that's
it I take two points in space like on a
plane there's there's exactly one line
that goes through them so this might
seem like okay that that seems pretty
obvious maybe but not entirely clear
what the relationship is between that
and communication but it turns out that
this idea is at the heart of lots of
analyses and constructions of error
correcting codes these communication
systems that have been used since the
60s and it's extremely fundamental so in
the second part of this talk I will sort
of talk about this idea a little bit to
talk about how we can generalize it and
talk about the mathematics of how this
idea can be used to design communication
systems which are very powerful
and finally in the third part of the
talk I'm going to sort of move up to the
research frontier so this idea and the
codes that are derived from that had
actually been around since the 60s so
they're you know pretty classical but it
turns out that there's lots of really
exciting new research being done in
coding theory and based on this idea in
particular today so in this last part of
the talk I want to focus in on a few
modern directions and once again there
are tons and tons of different research
areas that are active now that are very
exciting and I won't have time to talk
about them all but I'm just gonna pick
one one topic in computational biology
and kind of tell you guys how these
ideas in communication have been very
useful recently in something seemingly
unrelated computational biology so
that's the idea of the talk so I'll
start out talking about error correcting
codes what they are how they can how can
they be used to solve this problem and
we'll focus in on this one fundamental
idea and see how that in particular can
be used to solve this problem and then
we'll sort of dive ahead and see how it
can be solved used to solve not just the
problem of communication but tons of
other problems all the other problems
basically okay so that's the idea all
right so I said that for humans
repeating ourselves is pretty much okay
it's these other systems that we care
about we're repeating ourselves becomes
problematic that said when we talk about
error correcting codes a lot of times we
you know we like to anthropomorphize
things and so we often think about it as
humans communicating so I'm going to set
up the problem as sort of a toy problem
between two characters named Alice and
Bob so Alice is a sender and bob is a
receiver so Alice wants to send a
message to Bob and the problem is that
they were communicating in a noisy
environment right so why is this a
problem it's a problem because even just
a little bit of noise can have big
consequences so let me illustrate this
first by a kind of a silly example and
then we'll get a little bit less silly
but here's here's a first example of how
a little bit of noise can have big
consequences so suppose that Alice wants
to talk to Bob and Alice wants to talk
to Bob about panda bears okay and Alice
and Bob both agree panda bears are large
adorable mammals live in China eat
bamboo shoots and leaves right so Alice
says eats shoots and leaves Bob knows
exactly what she's talking about panda
bear eating plants so far so good
however this is a problem right turns
out that the way that alice has chosen
to express herself here is not very
robust in
presents of errors right so for example
I could change this message just a
little bit if I go and introduce just a
couple of changes a couple of commas
yeah all of a sudden this this phrase
means something slightly different and
Bob might get confused right so instead
of thinking about a panda bear who's
eating plants he's gonna think about
someone maybe a panda bear who eats is
it a hamburger shoots as in a gun and
leaves as in skedaddle and this is this
is not the message that Alice meant to
say this is terrible everything's gone
wrong horrible miscommunication okay so
what can they do about this so just like
we were saying before you know maybe
Alice could choose a way to express
herself that were a little less
susceptible to this sort of error right
so for example she could just shout
panda eats plants repeatedly okay and
Bob would probably get the idea but
again this has downsides you know has
the downside that Alice looks kind of
silly it has the downside that she
spends a lot of time communicating and
we want to know is this really the best
thing she could do to get her message
across right so the question we want to
answer is what is the best way to
introduce this redundancy and that's
where Eric correcting codes come okay so
that was my silly example let's step
back from this silly example a little
bit still with the cartoon pandas though
they're gonna be here for the rest of
the talk and try to figure out what
exactly is going on it's trying to
formalize this problem a little bit so
we can actually solve it okay so what's
going on so in the previous example
Alice wanted to talk to Bob and she
wanted to send him one of two messages
right either she was gonna say hey Bob
panda eats plants or she was going to
say hey Bob watch out pandas got a gun
right and Bob's job was just as
distinguished between these two messages
and the problem in the previous slide
was that Bob could not distinguish
between these two messages in the
presence of noise so more generally we
might imagine that Alice actually wants
to send not just one of two messages but
maybe one of a whole host of panda
related messages right maybe all of
these things so how are they gonna do
this alright so Alice and Bob so again
they're being proxies for other sorts of
communication devices so being normal
human beings who are proxies for other
sorts of communication devices Alice and
Bob of course communicate in zeros and
ones alright so a very natural way for
them to try to solve this problem is to
assign a string of zeros and ones to
each of the
possible messages so I've got I've got
eight messages here and there are eight
strings of zeros and ones at length
three and so I've assigned just one of
these strings to each of these possible
messages and so if Alice wants to say
panda eats plants she's gonna send Bob
the Panda eats plants string so zero
zero zero right and Bob knows exactly
what she's talking about
so this is the analog of the kind of not
very good scheme that we saw before the
Pawnee English sentence right because if
even one bit gets flipped Bob gets the
wrong idea so the solution is very
fragile and actually this is even worse
because if I if I flip another bit Bob
gets a completely different idea so this
is this is really not not very robust so
what can they do okay so the first thing
we would try is repetition right so we
might try let's take these messages and
just repeat them three times so instead
of zero zero zero I'm going to have zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
this time zero zero one I'm gonna have
zero zero one zero zero one zero zero
one and so on
and this actually works if Alice and Bob
are only trying to protect against one
bit getting flipped right because if
Alice wants to say hey Bob panda eats
plants she sends him this string of
three copies of zero zero zero and if
one error occurs Bob actually he's
pretty good he can still figure out what
Alice meant to say right because there
were three copies here and only one of
them got corrupted so he can just look
at this and he can say okay the vote is
two against one that Alice meant to say
Pandey's plants so I'm just going to I'm
gonna go with that and he'll be right in
this case so this works this works great
I mean there's only one error the
problem as we've discussed before is
that I had to you know go to a really
tiny font even to fit these strings
below my cartoon pandas right this is
these are a lot of bits there's a lot of
communication we might ask is there some
middle ground between the three bits
solution that was extremely brittle and
the nine bit solution that was actually
pretty robust at least to one error and
the answer turns out to be yes so here's
here's another solution so this solution
uses six bits per message okay so for
each of these messages I've assigned a
string of six bits and I've picked these
strings very carefully they have the
property that any two of them differ in
at least three play
so you can check me if you don't believe
me but I promise it's true ever any two
of these strings differ and at least
three places so why is this good for
Alice and Bob well it means that if
Alice wants to say panda eats plants
she'll send Bob the all-0 string okay so
far so good and now what happens if one
bit gets flipped so if one bit gets
flipped this string well it's one away
from the string that Alice meant to send
and because they're all three apart that
means it's at least two away from all of
the other strings so what Bob can Bob do
he can go and look at all of the
possible strings that Alice might have
sent and say uh what I heard is closest
to this one so I'm gonna go with that
and in this case if there's only going
to be one error Bob will be right some
expense cool and so this this works no
matter what bit got flipped right if a
different bit got flipped same argument
holds and it also works no matter what
message Bob meant to say or Alice meant
to say right so if alice meant to say
that panda for example then she would
send me back panda string and even if
one bit got flipped Bob would correctly
interpret that panda so this is great so
this is an example of an error
correcting code that is an error
correcting code for the purposes of this
talk it's just a whole bunch of strings
which we call code words that are all
mutually far apart and so now there's
there's a whole bunch of trade offs we
can talk about in this space right you
know how many sets of strings how many
strings do we have this sort of talks
about how many messages Alice could
possibly send to Bob how expressive is
their conversation another thing we care
about is how far apart these are so in
the previous slide all the code words
differed on exactly three bits or at
least three bits which meant that they
could tolerate one error and you could
imagine if these things are further
apart and differ on more bits than Alice
and Bob could tolerate more errors so we
also want that to be big and finally we
want the length to be small right the
whole point is to reduce overhead reduce
the amount of stuff that Alice has to
say because this turns out to be really
costly in applications so these sort of
three parameters that were whether we're
trading off between gives us a really a
really rich space to explore
okay so era crafting codes have actually
been around for a long time they were
introduced in the late 40s early 50s by
the seminal work of Claude Shannon and
Richard Hamming so these guys were
researchers at Bell Labs at the time and
they were really interested in sort of
the fundamental mathematics of
communication if I expect so many errors
or errors in this model how much can I
hope to communicate at what rate can I
hope to communicate and they really sort
of laid out the foundation of basically
all of modern information theory and
coding theory and there are many big
questions that they ask the big
questions were mostly about these
trade-offs right so the one that's sort
of relevant to this talk is is this one
that I was talking about before what are
the best trade-offs you can get between
the definitions of being big and far
apart and the length of these strings
using the definition the narrow
correcting code is a big set of strings
that are all far apart about these trade
offs another question that we might ask
that has been asked since is as clicker
doesn't work very well how can we
achieve these good dre trade-offs with
efficient algorithms right so in the
previous slide what what method did Bob
used to recover Alice's message well he
looked through all of those eight
strings and he figured out which one was
closest to what he heard so this works
great when there are eight strings but
imagine that maybe they're actually
something like to to the tune of the
eight strings or more you know what does
Bob do then he could look over them all
but it would take him a really long time
and so one question that we also ask in
coding theory is how can we achieve
these trade-offs they'll find these big
sets of strings that are structured in a
really nice way that allow Alice and Bob
to take advantage of this
computationally so that they can somehow
faster than just by looking at all the
strings figure out the Bob can figure
out what Alice meant to say so these are
these are big questions in coding theory
and in general they are still open so we
don't know the answers to these fully
these are huge open questions that said
we do know a lot and error correcting
codes have really evolved a lot since
the 50s and by now they're used
basically everywhere you look so they're
not just helpful for my you know silly
story about Alice and Bob the cartoon
people you know they're also useful
basically anywhere you could imagine
communication happening so for example
between your cell phone and a cell tower
there's an error of correcting code
they're fixing that between satellites
and satellite dishes they're also really
useful in storage so so far we've been
talking to us about communication but
you can imagine that the same principle
applies to storage right I have some
data and I I want to go put it somewhere
like on a disk and then something bad
might happen to it you know it's might
degrade just degrade things catch on
fire terrible stuff happens and we want
to be able to protect ourselves against
this and so one way to do it is to take
your data you know treat that as a
message it's a cartoon panda find the
code word associated with it and then
put that on your disk instead so then
it's robust against errors that might
happen in storage they're also used in
things like barcodes and QR codes so
this is the QR code on the poster
there's an aircraft in code and again
the same principle holds right you know
when your phone tries to read a QR code
maybe bits of it get get occluded bits
of it get covered up your phone doesn't
read it quite right you want it to be
able to be robust to any errors that are
introduced in the reading process so
that's an error correcting code as well
similarly internet protocols use error
correcting codes anywhere you could
think RAM also it's useful in areas that
you might not think so for example in
computer security there's lots of
protocols that are used crypto systems
which are based on ideas from error
correcting codes similarly it's really
useful in algorithm design for image
processing and computational biology
which you might not expect because those
don't seem immediately related to
communication but at the end of this
talk we'll will sort of explain at least
how the computational biology connection
goes okay so error correcting codes used
all over the place
and unfortunately today we cannot talk
about all of them so today instead I'm
going to focus on just one particular
idea one particular way to generate all
of these far apart strings but that's
really our goal is how do we get all
these strings that are so far apart and
this idea like I said earlier is that
two points determine a line so in order
to explain exactly what that means and
how it can help us create these big sets
of strings I need just one mathematical
tool
which are polynomials so I promise this
is the most technical side that's it so
here are polynomials here's a couple of
examples of polynomials so for example
this this polynomial y equals x squared
minus 1 this is a degree 2 polynomial so
the 2 is this this degree here and it's
associated with a graph like this you
know and how do we get this graph well I
called this x axis the x axis I call
this axis the y axis and you know if I
take X equal 0 for example and plug it
into this equation I get y equals 0
minus 1 which is minus 1 so I put a
little point there right here at minus 1
and if I plug in for example x equals 1
I get 1 minus 1 y equals 0 so I put a
little point at x equals 1 y equals 0
and if I do this for all the points I
get this this nice curve here that's a
polynomial this one is also a polynomial
this is a degree 3 polynomial so 3 is
this just biggest power that shows up
there okay so polynomials ok so the idea
that I wanted to talk about was that two
points determine a line so another name
for a line is a degree one polynomial
right so if I have two points here there
is a unique degree one polynomial that I
can draw through these two points so
here it is so there's my two points and
in this case here was my degree one
polynomial my line and actually this
this idea generalizes just a little bit
oh yeah so these two points are enough
to determine a line but they're actually
not enough to determine a degree two
polynomial right so if I take these two
points there's actually tons of degree
two polynomials that go through these
two points there's tons of parabolas
that I can draw through them so maybe
Alice likes this purple one here the guy
and Bob likes that green one there and
there's tons out there we can all pick
our favorite you know parabola that goes
through these two points
so not determined however if I had a
third point there then it turns out that
there is a unique parabola that goes
through those three points so to see
this you can either stare at the picture
for a little bit and be like yeah I
don't really see how to fit any other
parabolas there another way to see it is
just sort of by thinking of the degrees
of freedom you have so a quadratic
polynomial has
form y equals ax squared plus BX plus C
so sort of three things that you get to
control there there's a there's B and
there C so it's kind of like if you pick
three things then you've pinned down
exactly what this degree two polynomial
should be and here I get to pick three
points that's like three things so at
least morally speaking stuff kind of
adds up okay so three points determine a
degree two polynomial and more generally
K points determine a degree K minus one
polynomial so here's six points I guess
and here's the unique degree 5
polynomial that goes through okay this
makes sense
cool okay so the question you might have
at this point is yeah all right what's
so great about this this seems pretty
clear so this idea of course is very old
you know the Greeks knew about
polynomials but the idea of using these
for communication dates back to 1960
with a curving Reed and Gustav Solomon
these guys so they were researchers at
Lincoln labs at MIT and they were
thinking about communication and
thinking about how they could design
these coding schemes this is ten years
after after Shannon and Hamming and they
they realized that they could use this
idea to make codes and these codes are
called reed-solomon codes so named after
these guys so how do they work
oh so yeah so let me tell you how these
guys can use this idea the two points
determine a line in order to define a
whole bunch of strings that are really
far apart remember that was our goal so
first I need to make just a slight tweak
on the model so we agreed sort of at the
beginning of the talk that normal human
beings communicate in zeros and ones and
I'm going to relax this a little bit so
I'm going to say instead of
communicating in zeros and ones Alice
and Bob are allowed to communicate in
numbers zero one two three four okay so
maybe instead of sending a string like
this how else would send a string like
that just zero one two three four and
we'll see why this is useful later just
one more note about modular arithmetic
so if Alice and Bob are only allowed to
use zero one two three four then zero
one two three four or let's just say
these are the only numbers allowed in
our universe from now on for the rest of
the talk
so how do we enforce that there's
obviously way more numbers in 0 1 2 3 4
so we work mod 5 and what that means is
I take all of these integers from
negative infinity up to positive
infinity and I'm going to turn them into
either a 0 or 1 or 2 or 3 or 4 so these
ones 0 1 2 3 4 I could just keep as they
are those are good and then going
forward I'm just gonna wrap around so 5
I'm going to call that to be the same as
0 6 is the same as 1 7 is the same as 2
and so on and going the other direction
I'll just wrap around the other way so
negative 1 is the same as 4 negative 2
is the same as 3 negative 3 is the same
as 2 and so on all the way back alright
so now we've changed our model a little
bit Alice and Bob are allowed to
communicate in 0 1 2 3 4 good ok so now
let's see how this idea that degree K
polynomial that K points determine a
degree K minus 1 polynomial can be used
to help Alice and Bob in this setting so
here's the idea so we have all these
messages here these panda related
messages and we're going to associate to
each one of them a polynomial let's say
a quadratic polynomial degree 2 okay so
here they are so I'll associate to panda
eats plants he gets this nice blue curve
go blue panda gets this green curve over
there I mean you Misha lump-sum
sometimes it gets a holler but I guess
not now all right jedi panda will get
this red curve bat panda gets the purple
curve and so on okay so how many curves
actually are there all right so I'm
going to include all of the polynomials
of the form ax squared plus BX plus C
where a B and C I am allowed to choose
to be 0 1 2 3 4 so how many of these are
there well there's three things that I
get to choose I get to choose 5
different things for each so that's 5
cubed equals 125 such polynomials so we
can imagine they're actually 125
messages here that are encoded by these
polynomials but I am NOT going to draw
125 pandas so this is this is what we
get okay so all of the message possible
messages are associated to a polynomial
and now what happens what if Alice do so
she suppose she wants to say panda eats
plants and panda eats plants is
associated with this nice polynomial
here
so what Ellis says
is basically just the evaluations of
this polynomial so she'll go and look at
zero and she'll say ah at zero the Y
value is three so her first thing she'll
say is three then she'll look at one and
she'll say ah at 1 the Y value is zero
so she'll say zero then she'll look at
two interesting ok at 2 the Y value is
negative one that's not allowed but
we'll come back to it so she'll say
negative one then she'll say ok what is
3 well the Y value at 3 is zero so then
she'll say is zero and then she'll say
what's the Y value at 4 well that's
three again so then she'll say 3 but we
just agreed negative 1 is not allowed so
she'll change that into a 4 because 4
negative 1 is equal to 4 mod 5 ok so now
that's what Alice will say that's what
she's going to send to Bob and this
gives us a mapping sort of a
correspondence between all of the
messages and all of these strings so
looks like this so we have all of these
messages 125 different messages
associated with 125 different strings
and when Alice wants to talk to Bob and
say panda eats plants she's gonna send
this string associated candy into place
ok so why is this a good idea so the
whole point of an error-correcting code
is that I have lots of strings that are
really far apart so I certainly got lots
of strings I've got more strength than
cartoon pandas that I want to draw which
is my definition of big but the now we
need to show are they actually far apart
and I claim that they are I claimed that
these strings have exactly the same
property as those strings we saw at the
beginning of the talk that any two of
these differ in at least three places ok
so let's see why that's true so imagine
that Alice wants to send one message and
it looks like this parabola here and if
she wanted to send another message say
Jedi panda she would send this parabola
here and what I need to show to convince
you that these are really far apart is
that no matter what two polynomials she
ends up choosing these things must
disagree in at least three places so
let's put them on top of each other so I
claim that they can only agree in two
places and the reason is because three
points determine a degree two polynomial
right if they agreed in three places
they would
to be the same polynomial and we decided
at the beginning that they were
different okay so that means that they
must only agree in two places but
there's only five places to begin with
right so if I if I only agree in two
places those two there must be three
places this one this one and this one in
which they disagree okay so that's it
that's the entire argument and really
the only fact we used is that three
points determine a quadratic polynomial
so now I've proven this claim any two of
these different at least three places
and that means that Alice and Bob can
use these to communicate just like they
could at the beginning of the talk if
Alice wants to say panda eats plants she
says three zero four zero three and if a
now it's not a bit but if a symbol gets
changed so before we could only have 0
to 1 and 1 to zero but now we can have
anything it can get change to anything
else so if that zero there got changed
into a to what Bob sees is still closer
to the panda eats plant string than it
is to any of these other things so
nobody's actually made substantial
progress over our beginning slide right
now I have 125 different messages cool
and so these are called reed-solomon
codes and more generally I can think
about polynomials of larger degree than
quadratic and I can think about letting
Alice and Bob use numbers bigger than 1
2 3 4 3 0 1 2 3 4 in general they could
actually go up to 0 1 2 3 up to P minus
1 where P is a prime and the scheme was
this scheme will still work and these
are called reed-solomon codes and we saw
Tinley codes it turns out show up all
over the place and so one of the reasons
is that they have this really nice
relationship between distance and length
they actually achieve the optimal
relationship sort of for this parameter
regime another reason goes back to this
efficiency thing that I was talking
about they're really nicely structured
there's lots of algebraic structure
they're having because they're based on
polynomials like this and what that
means is that when Bob is trying to
figure out what Alice meant to say he
doesn't actually have to look over all
possible polynomials instead he just
looks at what he gets which is you know
some points and all he has to do is like
kind of figure out which is the
polynomial that is closest to these
points and it turns out that that's
something that he can do efficiently
just using algebra he doesn't have to
you know exhaustively search over
all possibilities so for these reasons
reed-solomon codes have become very
popular so actually when they were first
introduced in 1960 I think they were
kind of regarded more as a mathematical
curiosity than anything feasible and the
actual first real algorithms for them
weren't developed until the mid 60s and
then the really fast algorithms for the
more developed until the 70s but by the
late 70s they they really sort of took
off and since then they are used in tons
of applications yes right yes oh this is
a very good point so the question is
well I was talking about polynomials and
I've been waving my hands as though this
is a real-valued polynomial and when I
loop things around isn't that
introducing more errors and it turns out
via the magic of algebra that as long as
I move things around with a prime
modulus it actually works out okay so
this is not at all obvious but it turns
out to work if I tried to move things
around with a modulus that wasn't a
prime then you're right that that would
actually cause problems but yeah this is
this is one of the the great facts of
algebra is that if you work modulo a
prime a lot of the things that you
expect to be true over the reals in fact
are still true over these things they're
called finite fields and actually more
generally this works over any finite
fields not just ones of prime order but
ones of prime powered order as well yeah
so great question thanks any other
questions awesome
okay so we Selma coat so where have we
seen this before so I claim that you you
actually encounter these things every a
in fact many of the applications that we
saw before use reat element codes so CDs
DVDs blu-ray all of these use of reat
element codes in their error correction
barcodes and QR codes use three telamon
codes so this right this is the the
picture on the poster for this talks
this is my face in a QR code and this is
a really cool website called QR key you
should go take a look at it but
basically what this is doing is it's
searching over all of the possible
polynomials that could possibly encode
the website for the Simons Institute
which is where this QR code links and it
finds one that just happens to look like
my face it is really cool right that's
that's that's a legit polynomial there
those zeros are there like those pixels
are encoding a polynomial that happens
to look like my face I find that really
cool so they're used in these codes are
used in storage so raid 6 action which
is a storage thing for you for doing
stupid storage among several hard drives
uses reed-solomon codes it's actually
also used in data centers so Facebook's
data center uses reed-solomon codes for
for error correction
they're used in DSL they're you they
were used in the the Voyager probe the
spacecraft so all those cool pictures
that you've seen coming back from Uranus
or whatever those were all read Salman
encoded to make it through space so all
using polynomials using this idea that
two points are terminal line they're
also used in cryptography so basically
the the idea behind reed-solomon codes
this sort of idea of using polynomials
is also really helpful in something
called secure multi-party computation
which lets you know people try to
commute try to compute things jointly
when they don't want anyone else to know
their secret data this is also very
useful in crypto and it turns out to be
useful in actually all sorts of areas of
algorithm design for image processing
computational biology in other areas
like that
oops okay so read Salomon codes I said
this idea has been around since the 60s
and reed-solomon codes have been used in
practice since sort of the late 70s
early 80s
so surely everything there is to know
about these things are known right so
what what is there still to do and
actually I think that working in coding
theory today you've been working on
neoclassical things like polynomials and
reed-solomon codes is a really exciting
area of research for a number of reasons
so one thing that's super exciting is
that there's lots of new application
areas for these codes which are raising
new questions about them so one really
good example is distributed storage so
in modern storage centers you have all
of these different nodes and you have
some data and you want to distribute
this data to all these different nodes
and sort of the model that we're working
with for this these data centers is that
you know you have a lot of cheap
computers and they fail a lot of the
time so you want to use some sort of
encoding to protect your data in case
your servers fail so this makes various
natural sense for why you'd want to use
an aircraft in code but if you think
about it sort of the model here is
really different mathematically speaking
from the model we are talking about
beginning where I'm sending some radio
wave through space and I'm expecting a
whole lot of things to get corrupted and
I don't know which ones were corrupted
and there's lots here it's just like one
server fails at a time I know which one
because it's the one that's down and it
turns out that this creates a really
different parameter regime really
different questions and there's all
sorts of exciting research going on
nowadays for how do we best use these
codes or how can we best modify these
codes for use in distributed storage and
data centers and there's actually a lot
of really cool work here at Berkeley
being done in this particular area so
it's one example of modern research in
error correcting codes which is driven
by modern technology new new questions
another area of research is old
questions so it turns out there's lots
of old hard questions which are still
open for example the geometry of
reed-solomon codes is one of them that I
really like to think about so you can
think about these questions in coding
theory as kind of a geometry problem
so here this big green oval here this is
my artistic rendition of all of the
strings of length five right you can
looks just like it right yeah okay and
there in the middle I've highlighted
these red dots are supposed to be the
special ones that correspond to cartoon
pandas the ones that correspond to
messages and what we talked about before
is this kind almost geometric property
right that any two of these things
differed in at least three places okay
so if I in my little cartoon here I
could say that all of these dots are at
least three apart pairwise but we might
ask other geometry questions about this
we might ask well how are these dots
kind of distributed in this space are
there are there spaces or there are
there points where there's big holes
where there's not too many dots or there
places where there's tons of dots kind
of clustered together or tested as
clustered as tightly together as they
could be conditional audible having
distance three and it turns out that for
a lot of these questions we don't know
the answer um because unfortunately it's
not as simple as drawing a big green dot
and putting a whole lot of a big green
oval and putting a whole lot of red dots
in it and saying we understand what it
looks like in reality this geometry
problem it's it's really high
dimensional and the geometry that you're
thinking about it's not really sort of
Euclidean geometry like we think about
in 3-space because you know this
distance is some sort of discrete notion
of distance and so there's a lot of
really beautiful math questions that
arise from this that are super
interesting I'm still don't know the
answer to so that's another area of
active research and finally another
third area of active research in coding
theory and era crafting codes is
thinking about how we can apply these
codes in a wider and wider and wider
range of applications so we started out
talking about just communication
hopefully I've convinced you there may
be also useful in storage as well but it
turns out that they pop up all over the
place not just where you might think
like communication and storage so
invention a couple examples about
computer security they're really useful
in image processing signal processing
and today I'm going to talk about how
they're useful in computational biology
right so these reed-solomon codes you
saw all over the place unfortunately I
don't have time now to talk about
everything so I'm gonna spend sort of
the last 15 minutes or so of this talk
just focusing in on one particular
example
computational biology so before I move
on are there any any questions about the
set up but these things are the
mathematical mathematics behind them
okay
onwards so let's see an example of how
this can be used in something that on
the surface has nothing to do with
communication so I'm going to talk about
a problem called combinatorial group
testing which has showed up recently in
computational biology so here's the
group testing problem right so actually
I was I was trying to decide what should
I talk to you about right for a specific
application for it for sort of a modern
topic and there's so many good topics I
really wanted to pick something that had
some good theory I wanted to pick
something that was actually relevant in
practice and most importantly I wanted
to pick something that I could explain
in 20 minutes using only cartoon pandas
and so it's actually narrowed it down
significantly less than you might think
but but here I've converged on this
computational biology application with
my cartoon pandas okay so here I have
seven pandas and it's important to note
that now these are representing actual
pandas they're not representing messages
this is an important distinction because
actual pandas can get sick okay so let's
say that some of these pandas are sick
but they're asymptomatic we don't know
which ones are sick we would like to
learn which ones are sick so what can we
do well one thing we can do is you know
test them we take a blood sample from
every panda run some science test
that's a beaker for science right and
figure out which ones are positive which
ones are negative and let's suppose
we're living in kind of this ideal world
where we don't have any false positives
we don't have any false negatives
everything's just perfect nice clean
data um this is obviously not the case
in the real world but for now let's
let's imagine that okay so I get I see
that some pandas testing positive some
pandas tested negative and I correctly
conclude which ones tested positive okay
so this is great except you could
imagine if these tests are kind of
costly this maybe we don't want to do
this testing everybody might be very
expensive
we want to might want to ask can we do
better so to motivate this a little bit
let me
me tell you the original application of
combinatorial group testing which
surprisingly was not testing cartoon
pandas for a mysterious illness actually
it first arose in world war ii where the
army wanted to test soldiers for
syphilis so it turns out some soldiers
had syphilis not too many and at the
time syphilis tests were extremely
expensive and so the army just didn't
have the resources to individually test
every soldier for syphilis so the idea
that they came up with was to start
pooling blood samples and so it turns
out if you pooled the blood sample to
different soldiers if you kind of
assumed that not too many of them were
sick you could get away with using many
fewer blood samples so let's see how
this works with our cartoon panda thing
let's let's uh suppose just for a minute
that there's only one stick panda
how would we figure out with fewer than
seven tests which one it was so again
the key is to pool blood samples so
here's a pooling design
oh you can't really tell these we're
supposed to be red and those ones
they're supposed to be yellow but they
kind of show up the same but anyways
here's a way to to pool blood samples
and I claim that this will do the job
right so for example suppose that I do
this and I run my tests and I find out
that this one comes out positive
this one comes out negative and this one
comes out positive also alright which
panda was sick any guesses
that panda that panda was sick right and
the way we can tell bat panda was sick
was because he was the only one who
participated in these two tests right if
I assume that there's only one panda
who's sick it must be this guy because
every other guy participates in some
different sequence of tests and this
this works
so this works you know no matter what
sequence I got so for example if I saw
all three of these showing up I would
assume that private-eye panda was the
sick one because he's the only one who
participates in all three tests so this
is example of how by doing pooling we
can reduce the number of tests we need
from seven to three so it's pretty good
okay so that's that's what happens if
one panda is sick
more generally meaning that we might ask
what happens if many pandas are sick
multiple ones what can we do so we still
want to go pull blood samples right so
the game is the same we have some sick
Santa's we don't know which ones are
sick and we are allowed to pull samples
so we could take blood from this Panda
and blood from this panda mix it
together and we get positive because
there was at least one sick panda in the
pool similarly if we took blood from
these two pandas we'd still get positive
we wouldn't get any information about
how many pandas were sick we just get
the one bit of information positive on
the other hand if we saw this scheme or
this set it would come out negative
because neither of those pandas were
sick okay
so the rules are clear so then the
question is alright so if I'm allowed to
pool blood samples and I know that there
are K sick pandas how many tests do I
need right how few tests can I get away
with in order to identify the kasich
pandas so it turns out once again I
guess this is the theme of this talk
actually this question is still open to
we don't know precisely the answer but
we do have some pretty good schemes and
some of the best schemes are based on
error correcting codes and in fact based
on reed-solomon codes so let's see how
this works so what is the connection
between this and coding theory okay so
here's all my pandas there's still
real-life pandas who might get sick but
now I'm going to identify them with the
message pandas that were in the previous
part of the talk and I'm going to
identify each of those with one of these
reed-solomon code words that we came up
before so here's this here's this Reed
Solomon code that we had before so to
each Panda I'm going to associate a
string of length five with numbers 0 1 2
3 4 and just to remind you the key of
that these strings was that any two of
them differed in at least three places
and moreover we actually had 125 of them
right so I'm not going to draw all this
pandas but they're 125 pandas now some
of whom might be sick ok so how does
this scheme work how can we use
reed-solomon codes to identify the sick
pandas alright so here's here's this
solution here's a pooling design so I'm
gonna tell you how to distribute this
pandas blood into 25 possible pools okay
so this means that we had 125 pandas
let's assume two of them are sick I'm
going to show you how to get away with
only 25 tests instead of 125 so this is
this is pretty good okay so what do we
do so I'm gonna take this panda let's
say that this is his reed-solomon code
word 3 1 2 & 3 I'm going to write that
up on the top here of this grid and then
I'm going to distribute his blood
according to these numbers like that so
in this column I'm going to put this
pandas blood into the third into bucket
number 3 because there's a 3 here in
this column I'm going to put his blood
into bucket number 1 because there's a 1
here and so on all the way across ok
and I claim that this works so why does
this work so let's suppose that this
Panda is healthy and that the 2 other
sick pandas are some other pandas or
sick
so now what happens where did where does
the actual blood that would test
positive go well remember any of these
strings differ in at least 3 places that
means that they can agree and in most
two places so let's say that go blue
panda is string agrees with panda has a
gun string in say the first two places 3
1 and then these things which do not
agree with this guy's right so that
means that this Panda is positive blood
would show up in these two pools but in
none of these three pools and now we'll
do it again with Jedi panda let's say
you know in the worst case Jedi Panda
agrees with this guy and in two other
positions that
hardly taken by this one so let's say he
agrees and the two and the one but these
other three must be different so then
his sick blood shows up in this pool in
this pool but not in the other three and
the key point here is that this leaves
one possible pool uncovered right so
there's one guy uncovered it has no
positive blood in it so it's going to
come up negative and this means that I
observed that this pandas blood went
into this test and this test came up
negative so it must be that this panda
is healthy so I can certify that this
kind of is healthy and actually this
works for any of the panda so all the
healthy pandas I can certify their
health by just saying okay look there
was a pool where they they didn't come
up which didn't come out positive so
they must be healthy and the two sick
pandas are precisely those pandas for
whom all of their tests came up positive
so here's a solution and turns out this
is actually one of the best solutions we
know to this problem in general fully
and it's been used a lot so just to put
this in a little bit of context
let me give you sort of a brief history
of group testing so like I'm entering
poop testing was sort of introduced in
the 40s in World War two by Dorfman for
precisely this problem of figuring out
which soldiers had syphilis and then
some time passed and then in the 60s
Reid and Sullivan did their work and
invented reed-solomon codes which is
what we just saw and in a few years
later in 1964 captain singleton came up
with this idea of using reed-solomon
codes using error correcting codes to
solve the group testing problem okay so
this is all still very old work very
classical what's going on since then
well since then the the path kind of
diverged a little bit so in this top
path this is sort of the theory path and
so you can think this this question how
many tests do you need to decide which
which K pandas are sick this is a really
nice math question it's got some great
combinatorics it's just so
mathematicians basically went crazy
right for like 50 years
it was proving all sorts of things you
know probably trying to prove lower
bounds like I said it's still open but
there's been a lot of really beautiful
work in combinatorics trying to close
these gaps the computer scientists work
really hard to find
very fast algorithms to do this so the
algorithm that I described in the
previous slide was we'll just kind of
look at every panda and see whether or
not all their tests came up positive
that's pretty efficient but you can
actually do much more efficient than
that you can actually just look at all
the tests and not have to look at every
panda just look at all the tests and be
like oh it's bat Panda bat pandas the
one and this actually allows you to have
sub linear time algorithms so really
fast algorithms and also really nice
constructions that are very structured
and and very explicit so tons of really
cool theory work has been done on the
other end of things this is sort of the
practice side
well syphilis test became cheap
eventually people stopped using this to
test soldiers for syphilis because we
don't care so much anymore but then this
idea resurfaced in the 90s in
computational biology for
high-throughput screening so instead of
soldiers you have civilians and instead
of blood samples you have DNA samples
and you want to run some sort of genetic
tests on these samples and these tests
are very costly and so in the 90s
computational biologists started
realizing that they could pool blood
samples and you know make much better
use of their resources so they started
doing this and won their own like as a
community they sort of investigated
these pooling designs which ones were
best which ones worked better than
others and in in 2006 Oh Nicolo Theory
meg introduced something called the
shifted transversal design or
unfortunately STD different communities
so but these designs were really really
nice they had all sorts of beautiful
combinatorial properties they worked
really nice and practice with the types
of pooling you know the sort of the
biology technology that people were
using like the robots which do pooling
and stuff these these worked they were
very very structured they worked very
well and people started using them so
they started using them precisely for
this DNA screening application so this
is a this is a picture of a robot that
does this pooling so it goes in it
shoots up DNA samples and it goes and
cools them down in a plate and it does
this repeatedly hi so sorry using this
um it turns out this is also useful for
genome sequencing de novo genome
sequencing so basically this is a little
more complicated to see why this
but basically the idea is you want to
sink with some genome it's very
expensive one thing you can do is chunk
up the genome into chunks and then you
pull these chunks and what you get out
are little pieces of information called
reads and you want to somehow assign
reads to belong to certain chunks and
the way these chunks are chosen to be
overlapping it can be the case that not
too many chunks are responsible for any
particular read and once again you get
this group testing problem you want to
know which chunks were responsible for
the read and then you can use this to
help assemble the genome again okay so
this is all very exciting and one thing
that I think is extremely exciting is
that now all of a sudden these
communities have started to come back
together um so this is a great story
that I love to tell so I was once at a
workshop in 2013 at the IMA at Minnesota
and this workshop was organized to bring
together these two communities so the
organizers had realized that there were
these two different communities
computational biologists and theoretical
computer scientists who had been
thinking about this problem in parallel
for really long time and hey gosh maybe
would be good to get us all in a room
for a week so they did that and what we
discovered there
so basically Niklas Harry meg was giving
his talk about shifted transversal
designs and a coding theorist Audrey
Rudra stood up in the back of the room
and said you've invented reed-solomon
codes and in fact he was right so shift
and transversals eyes are just read
Solomon codes the computational
biologist had discovered them on their
own
which I think really speaks to the
through the fundamental nature of these
polynomials and this actually led to a
lot of really cool collaborations so
going both ways so from the
computational biology side there's all
sorts of these new problems and new
settings that the theorists hadn't been
thinking about because you know often
Theory la-la-land maybe you haven't
thought about it and then from the other
side there's ways to use these really
fast algorithms and explicit
constructions in practice so one
particular example in this pooling for
genome sequencing this is a setting
that's a little it's a little different
than sort of the standard you've got
Kasich pandas and you want to figure out
which ones are sick it's it's just a
slight tweak on it
and so it turns out that you know using
ideas from the theory community they
were able to you know import some really
fast algorithms to do this and really
speed up their process and going the
other way it gave some new models for
the three community you think about
which is really exciting another great
example of just how theory can theory
and practice can talk to each other so
the computational biologist had
discovered with Salomon codes but they'd
only discovered it over prime fields so
before we were talking about all the
numbers in the world are zero one two
three four and I mentioned that actually
we could generalize this all the numbers
in the world are zero one two three four
up to P minus 1 where P is a prime
because that's what makes you know the
arithmetic work out to answer your
question um but it turns out even more
generally there's something called a
finite field over which these schemes
work and finite fields come in two
flavors they come in flavors prime sized
and power of prime sized and the power
of prime sized by which I mean like
three cubed is a power of a prime
there's three is a prime right so power
of prime sized fields are much less
intuitive to think about you can't just
think about modular arithmetic like this
they actually require a little algebra
and so the computational biologists
haven't figured this out yet because you
know why would you if you don't have a
background in algebra um but it turns
out that the biology equipment they were
using you know sort of standard issue
can't be changed
comes in certain sizes like the the
plates that they pool things in have 96
wells so this is an industry standard
can't be changed and it turns out if you
want to work with things that are prime
sized this is kind of obnoxious like it
did when you're designing these pooling
schemes what you would really like to be
able to do is use an alphabet of size 16
so you know Alice and Bob are allowed to
use 16 different characters but if
you're restricting yourself to a prime
well you can use 13 or you can use 17
and these didn't really play nicely with
the with the biology equipment that they
were using but sort of as soon as we
have this conversation they're like oh
16 is a power of a prime we can do that
too and all of a sudden variable - much
better utilize the resources it's cool
story and it
so this is just one example of the many
different ways that reed-solomon codes
show up in current research in areas
that you might not even think of like as
being anything related to communication
SiC pandas
so reed-solomon codes are all over the
place here's one example and I just want
to sort of conclude with some of the
punch lines of the talk so what did we
talk about so the main takeaway is
should be two points two terminal line
repeating yourself is not the best way
to communicate and in fact both of these
have implications far beyond
communication for example the
computational biology but also to lots
of lots of other areas okay so with that
I'll finish talking and take any
questions that you have yeah right yes
oh that's a very important thing that
yeah so I was saying these arrows by
both ways right so one one thing that we
learned when talking to the
computational biologists is that our
models of errors were not exactly
accurate yeah so there's there's some
several things you can do so one thing
is you can you can model the errors
either as worst-case errors so you can
model them as random errors and then you
do need to change the schemes a little
bit to be robust to that but yeah you're
absolutely right that's an important
consideration any other question yeah
I have a similarity of some kind to
compress sensing right because the
server lies the fact that there's a
small fraction of people that are
positive in order for it to work is
there a formal connection of some kind
so there's a there's like a very close
connection so he right so the question
is what is the relationship between this
and compress sensing so in compress
sensing it's it's very similar so
interesting you have this big long
matrix and a sparse vector right and you
see the output of this matrix vector
multiplication and your goal is to
recover the the big sparse vector and
you can think about group testing here
as actually having a very similar
framework semantically speaking you have
a big binary matrix which represents
your pooling design and you're
multiplying it by a sparse vector but
now the multiplication is over a boolean
algebra instead of over the real number
oh sorry you said yes Ted over the real
numbers and this is heard of taking into
account the fact that even if too sick
pandas participated in the same pool you
only get one bit of information you
don't get the answer to you get the
answer yes so it's basically the same
problem except instead of having plus
you have or instead of having times you
have and so that said the mathematics
actually turns out to be slightly
different in terms of the type sorts of
guarantees you can get so I guess
asymptotically speaking if you want to
recover a K sparse vector using
compressed sensing you need about K log
n measurements for group testing turns
out you need about K squared log n
measurements and the extra squared is
coming precisely from this difference in
the algebraic model but yeah you're
right they're extremely closely
connected and actually ideas from group
testing and compressed sensing and
coding Theory actually have you know
really intermingled that's very exciting
area of research
yeah I drew the pandas yeah but before I
was a computer scientist I was once
thought I might be a studio art major
but I change my mind for error
correcting codes are for group testing
yeah so the answer is uh I'm not sure um
yeah I don't know it yeah yeah I mean so
people do use no optical networks to
communicate sometimes which really does
go with the speed of light because
that's what it is I'm not sure if yeah
actually I don't on the answer to your
question that's the interesting question
yeah huge distances oh so I got the
impression they're just using repetition
I'm not using some error correcting
codes am I wrong how do they communicate
these photographs so there might be some
satellites that are using repetition but
definitely many use error correcting
codes so for example boya juror uses
reed-solomon codes most satellites you
know from what you get satellite TV use
something called turbo codes or LDPC
codes so most of them do use some sort
of aircraft a visit would be
reed-solomon codes with a sort of very
high p you're doing modulo prime ah
that's right well right so the the
question is how do you turn these
reed-solomon codes which are over you
know number zero through P minus 1 into
bits or you know just something that you
can send so the way that people get
around that is something called
concatenated codes so basically I'll
take a Reed Solomon code and then I'll
look at each symbol and so this is the
symbols and number 0
P and also see it - each symbol I'll
actually encode that with a binary code
so I'll treat that symbol as a little
vector of zeros and ones and that's
actually what gets sent yeah exactly
thank you a thoroughly good question
well so two answers so the first answer
is that one thing that's going on there
is not so much that my it is that we are
as humans are doing error correction but
it's also that our ways of conveying
things have redundancy built in right so
like images are extremely redundant in
the sense that we can compress them a
lot right and you know for example
garbled speech is also you can figure
out what I mean to say even if I'm just
kind of muttering and the reason is that
English has a lot of redundancy built in
as well as your own brains or error
correction capabilities but the second
question then yeah that's really
interesting so the could we somehow mix
human computation with that's a break
computation
it might be that you can imagine coming
up with schemes with more efficient
decoding algorithms using biology
inspired decoding methods but yeah I
don't know that's a really good idea
okay all right yeah I'll figure it out
in the next whatever do have you can
sort of implement like an error event
parking scheme I thought you might talk
this into the stickers like we saw one
code but they do have the same
properties that like nearby you know
representation get mapped to the correct
message because because of convergence
of Hopkin networks type of neural
network so that is uh there is a
connection there
cool thank
mm I mean some people right yeah so
energy is is an important consideration
that people take into account so
certainly if you're sending fewer bits
you're using less energy to transmit but
I think what you're talking about is
then you know the computational cost for
encoding that also incurs an energy cost
and definitely when people design these
designs especially for things like
satellites which have to work on you
know wanting to conserve energy as much
as possible yeah exactly so you want
codes in fact reed-solomon codes can be
implemented very fast in hardware this
is very low energy implementations and
also all sorts of other families have
codes as well people think very hard
about that yeah yeah that's a really
good point
so you could feasibly use it inside a
chip I think that the types of codes
that are used on that scale so for
example in RAM I know that Hamming codes
are used which is a slightly different
type of code so certainly error
correction does happen at that level I'm
not sure we'd Solomon codes are the
optimal thing for that but yeah error
correcting codes down
thank you thank you thank you